remember this your mind is a weapon and
you got to be in to use it and pick that
weapon up and control it a good person
in any endeavor will only take from it
what they think they deserve wanna soar
and get a mentor
what's up beliefs nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best ed my let and how
to turn your mind into a weapon that
serves you mentor me and also if you
want to know what speakers like Tony
Robbins Grant Cardone Garrity and others
have to say about building on stoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is in
description below so while you're in
this passionate state that's where you
make decisions you have to go build
self-confidence the reason people don't
put themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one put your reticular activating system
to work do you ever think about what you
think about because if you did and if
you took control of that you could alter
the direction of your entire life
most people never take the time to take
an inventory about their thoughts yet
our thoughts control our world our
thoughts are like magnets they literally
draw towards us that's which we obsess
about and so most people never take the
time to analyze what they think about
the most successful people I know are
the most self-aware meaning they're
aware of what they do and they're also
aware of what they think they're aware
of how they're perceived remember this
your mind is a weapon and you've got to
be in to use it and pick that weapon up
and control it most people are out of
control with their mind they don't point
it at something they let the world point
it and they misfire all the time so
today I want you to pick up that weapon
that is your mind and begin to point it
at the things you want knowing that it's
a magnet that draws to you the things in
your life that you would most like to
have or that you would most not like to
have and that's where most people make
the mistakes in their life so today I
want you to begin with first taking an
inventory of the thoughts you have that
don't serve you and I want you to write
them down and I want you to eliminate
them step 1 write down the thoughts that
don't serve you and eliminate them how
do I eliminate them by replacement you
eliminate them with replacement by
thinking a new thought it's as simple as
saying what thought would I need to have
that would serve me to get this goal or
dream or vision that I have and get that
thought write it down repeat it over and
over and over and over again because
there's a part of our brain called the
reticular activating system the
reticular activating system is the
filter through which you see the entire
world it's powerful and so that's why it
filters out all the things in your life
that aren't important to you so that you
could be saying you don't feel the blood
rushing through your left ear you don't
you know you don't you're not conscious
of your breathing a million stimulus
would hit you if you couldn't filter
things out you'd go crazy this allows
you to only filter into your
consciousness what is most important to
you and what's most important to you is
what you think about all the time and it
creates a filter for example that's why
if something is important to you the
reticular activating it to you through
vision sound touch you name it it's
for example you ever buy a new car
you've got a new you know blue Honda car
all of a sudden don't you see that car
everywhere it's on the third give me
three lanes over other side of the
freeway you see blue Honda's all of a
sudden everywhere they were already all
over the road why do you see them all of
a sudden you ever noticed that before
because that's become important to you
because it's it's part of your reticular
activating system now so what if you
could program your mind that the blue
Honda's of your life or your goals your
dreams and your visions and the way we
do that is repeated thinking looking at
our goals visualizing them seeing them
over and over again so let me give you a
couple tips to do that number one your
smartphone you check about 400 times a
day 400 the most important thing you
could do is on your screen saver program
the thoughts that would serve you the
goals that would serve you that gives
you 400 triggers a day every time you
pick up this phone you're looking at
your blue Honda's you're looking at
what's most important to you what
happens is when you put that down the
RAS begins unconsciously to help filter
into your existence the people the
places the conversations the things that
will help you materialize that space
you've created with the thought it fills
it with the furniture of your life the
furniture of the people places and
things so the second thing is to program
your phone with your goals and dreams
that's 400 triggers a day to begin to
alter those 9 percent of your thoughts
that's my challenge to you as you
program that Ras what's going to begin
to happen is you're gonna begin and
you'll literally be sitting in a
restaurant 3 or 4 tables over as you're
in a conversation you ever had this
happen you just can't help but hear
somebody and that restaurant 3 tables
over you shouldn't be able to hear them
that you do and sometimes almost drives
you crazy doesn't like I can't get these
people out of my head why is it
sometimes you can hear these
conversations in a room or on an
airplane away from you and other times
you can't because somehow that
conversation became important to you and
the RAS filters it into you auditory
through your hearing and you begin to
hear it when you're obsessed with what
you want you begin to hear those
conversations when you're not obsessed
you miss them where you'll see something
that you wouldn't see you'll see the
prospect you'll see the situation you'll
see the opportunity it's literally
reveals it's almost like the matrix it
changes our world this is the power of
what we think about it's the most
misunderstood thing in the world it's
literally taking control of your
thoughts and pointing it
your life and your goals and your dreams
has a weapon to magnetize towards you
what you want and rule number two the
last one before very special bonus clip
is alter your beliefs so there's this
governor on our lives and it is a
governor and it's a it's your identity
it's this internal it's what you think
you're worth it's what you think you
deserve and the problem for good people
seat we all know someone right now in
our life where we have who's not ethical
who's not a good person who's winning
and you're like I can't believe they're
getting it right why can't I I'm a good
person I treat people while I'm honest
here's a reason why by the way the
unethical person eventually karma you
reap what you sow comes home to roost
but if you're a good person this is so
important people understand this because
it took me a long time a good person and
any endeavor will only take from it what
they think they deserve what they think
they're worth in other words if there
was a pizza here you're a good person
you don't take all 12 pieces a good
person thinks there should be an
equitable distribution layer so I might
take seven or eight arm-wrestle you for
I don't know about a your mousse but but
long story short what is is that you a
good person will not take more from the
table of life than they think they're
worth or they think they deserve and so
you have this governor on your identity
so what happens is our it's like a
thermostat our lives get going we start
doing really well if we're a 75 degree
or and our life gets to 85 and 90
degrees unconsciously we go we don't
know we're doing it oh we start to cool
life back down to get it back to where
we're comfortable that reverse is also
true when things start to go really bad
and you're broke and you're struggling
you find a way to heat your life back up
to what you think you're worth and you
deserve so the way we alter our life is
sure we got alter our behavior and our
relationships and our circumstances but
the only way it's permanent is that we
alter that governor that thermostat and
we start to believe we're worth
eighty-five degrees of life 95 degrees
of life 110 degrees of life and there's
ways we can alter that how do we alter
it a couple different ways a one is what
you just said is that you put yourself
in circumstances that are demanding if
you pass what you think your capacity is
and when you succeed at them you build a
new water line you do your you throw
yourself out there past where you're
comfortable and you do an 85 degrees
behavior
and you knock it out of the park ago ha
your brain starts to believe it
repetitiously when you start doing that
you build a new line now you're 85
degrees that's number one
the second way though is Association if
you're around people and whatever that
endeavor is if it's a sport you're in or
if it's a business or your faith or your
peace if you begin to associate with
people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heated up yeah so if
you're an athlete for example you're a
70-degree athlete and you start training
all the time with 85 and 90 degrees your
identity through osmosis goes up if your
person is trying to improve their faith
in their life or their their personal
piece about them you all know this
you've seen it when you start to hang
around people that are a little bit more
peaceful than you or meditate a little
bit more through that association over
time the thermostat changes in that area
and so it's both behaving in certain way
and then your associations yeah I
believe that now I've got opponents get
from Ed my lead on how to be specific
that I think you're really going to
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what beliefs do you
need to alter number two what specific
new belief do you need to replace it
with and number three how can you use
your reticular activating system to help
you I used to walk this Beach as a kid
and say this is where I want to live
someday I knew exactly what beach I knew
exactly the area and the more my brain
went to work on that specific thought
that specific place the more likely it
was to happen so remember this the more
specific you are with your thinking the
more intentional you are with the
thoughts the higher the probability of
it happening and your brain can go to
work that Ras can go to work on finding
the people places things and resources
to fill in that very specific thought
that you have so don't be general be
specific and repeat it over and over and
over again to yourself and you get a
whole lot more likely to happening
if you want more head my let Chucky the
motivation for 2019 video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction they don't
look at price they look at worth
identity is the governor on our lives